[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about life specifically your money
your work your relationships
and you know who knows we'll take your
question because it's a free call triple
eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number i'm ken coleman ramsey
personality
host of the ken coleman show on the
ramsey network joined by my colleague
john deloney he is the host of the dr
john delona's show
and also ramsey personality and
relationship guru
mental health emotional health we'll
talk about it all
i focus on purpose and work uh whether
that's just hey can
i need to make more money so i can get a
bigger shovel get out of debt faster
i want to get promoted so that i can do
the work that i was born to do we're
going to cover
all that plus your money questions today
john good to be with you sir
you too man are you ready to roll yeah
but i saw on the on the internets that
you got a big announcement you made this
week
yeah well no we haven't we haven't it
was you know what it was on social which
i don't understand because the the
social media team said
hey let's let's tell people about it so
it's on instagram yeah but then uh with
dave and i the other day i was like yeah
we'll wait till monday
so monday august the second will be the
big announcement will be the really big
announcement we have two
massive projects that you know i've
poured a lot of blood sweat and tears
into
yes and uh it's very exciting but if you
want it two more days
or you can go to my instagram account at
ken coleman and we we showed it there so
i don't know you see what i'm saying
they got a little electrical thing i saw
you just get it
if you talk about it too soon they'll
just zap you and then you know that's
not gonna be pretty for anybody that is
a part of um this world that for the
person just listening there's a lot of
people that control what we can say and
not say
and one of them is we got exciting
projects and we'll tell you later we'll
tell you when we're allowed to tell you
that's right yeah but i am excited uh
but thank you for bringing that but yeah
we we're really excited and you're
working on you're working on a book too
now
yeah come on that's you're in the throes
speaking of blood sweat
tears yeah there's a lot of tears which
do you have more of right now
blood sweat or tears or is it equally
distributed
it's just a mess it's a laundry day
after every riding day
yeah lots of late nights man where i'm
ready to get this thing i get it
i get it yeah we got big news uh so
we'll share that very exciting stuff
but hey it's all about you this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five we got a great looking
crowd in the lobby of ramsey solutions
here in nashville john they're fired up
uh i see some people wearing debt free
shirts we're probably going to talk to
them later
uh this is a reminder that that we are
open for business you can come see us
we got free cookies cold beverages hot
beverages
uh i should point out they're
non-alcoholic uh we
we don't have any i gotta point that out
you can bring your own flask you could
yes nobody's gonna nobody's gonna uh
check you out on that so there's a young
kid over there
he looks like he's got a flask too yeah
okay well we'll just keep an eye on him
during the show that could make it
really interesting
all right let's get to the phones shall
we let's go to
klamath falls oregon i hope i said that
right
crystal joins us there crystal how can
we help
hi uh john and ken i'm elated to talk to
you both
well we're excited to talk to you what's
up
um i actually had a two-part question
for you um
a little bit more targeted towards ken
i'm
a mom a foster mom a working
professional
in a great marriage that i've been in
for 17 years i'm nearly debt free
thanks wow way to go
but with all of that i'm also a former
foster youth
and i'm looking at creating some
multi-faceted training materials
for foster biological and adoptive
parents
and i'm in need of a mentor or a guide
for this process
i don't have but not just like any
mentor like somebody who's actually done
it for themselves maybe
that has created training materials
written books
etc i know all of the ramsey
personalities have done it so who do i
call
call a pastor a counselor is there a
website for mentors rs
yeah and the second part
and then the second part of the question
is how do you feel about
mentors who charge for money for their
time
that's not a mentor that's not a mentor
coach yeah that's a coach or an advisor
that you're paying a consultant so
don't do that per se until you figure
out what specifically
you need because you might need that
coach you might need that paid
advisor so let's break that down uh
you've done a great job of explaining
what you want to do you're going to be
in the content business that's what john
and i do
okay there's a why behind this it's a
beautiful why by the way
as an adoptive parent i got to tell you
love what you're doing you got a fan in
me
just want you to know that um and i love
your story
and i would love to know more about it
all right so what specifically
are we talking about the creation of the
content are we talking about
producing it once it's written or
created and getting it out there
is it about distribution is it all of
the above
um well it's i can already tell you that
i already have like my outline and my
introduction for my book i've already
gotten
a well i already have a multi-faceted
training program outlined
and a full detailed powerpoint
presentation prepared and i've had
numerous conversations with lots of
non-profits and state organizations
i'm not just sleeping on the job have
you gone out and
road tested this yeah have you met with
groups and given the presentations and
taught this stuff and had people give
you feedback on it
um that's kind of the step i'm in right
now one of the things i'm noticing is
that those programs that i'm
basically presenting the materials to
they all want the material but they
almost want to change the material into
to almost meet their mission and their
goals and it just doesn't feel in line
with where
i want it to be and where i want it to
go and where i feel like i'm being
called to go
and so i really just need somebody to
kind of be my accountability buddy
to issue me deadlines and then somebody
who will also be honest with me and tell
me if it totally stinks
yeah so let me get back to where we were
on the three things john's right you do
need to test it
but if you fully flush this out i know
you got the powerpoint but i don't
really that to me is not as important as
have you written all this out it sounds
like you've got a piloted version
right is that what i'm understanding i
do i have a piloted version
i do not have the full content and so i
almost need somebody to like
push and like give me like i need 20
pages by the end of the week yeah so
i there okay so now i would tell you
that i think it would be good for you to
kick the tires and talk to several
writing coaches
um i i'll tell you there's one that i
recommend i've interviewed her on my
show before
she's really good her name is ally
fallon
you can you can contact her i'm not
telling you she's the only one i'm just
telling you she's one that i know and
she's really really good at helping
people
um as she has a writing coach service
but there are others i want you to check
out at least three or four more
because if that's what you're needing is
the coaching plus
the accountability and the discipline to
finish this stuff
i think that would be wise to do but
then it's back to what john
asked about and that is how much have
you tested this
and you're going to run into some of
this stuff this frustration you have of
hey i presented this organization
and they didn't want to do it turnkey
and you're going to have to be okay with
that
yeah so i'll i'll put it this way as
nicely as i can i've written two
dissertations i've published
academically i've written a bestselling
book
and i tell you what i've had to have a
lot of people say john you think this is
good and it sucks
and it's a lot of editing a lot of
revising
a lot of hey this sounded good in my
head but it didn't work in reality for
this business or that person
that single mom so you're gonna have to
enter this process with a lot of
humility too
right take your idea and your passion
and let other people refine it refine it
refine it that's right
so get the coach finish it then test it
edit it test it again keep going with it
this is a marathon not a sprint
don't move this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show helping you
move forward on the path
that you have set out for yourself
whether it's financial or professional
or relational
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney we're taking your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five the housing market is
hot doc
it really is i mean it's unbelievable
what homes are going for
uh in our area and around the country
and your house could be worth a lot more
than it was when you bought it this
means your old insurance policy might
not give you enough coverage anymore
and what's the point of paying for
insurance that won't swing the cost to
repair or rebuild your home
some of the policies will automatically
raise your coverage to cover rising home
price
or material cost but not all of them so
if your home's value has gone up talk to
one of our endorsed local providers
these independent agents
will compare multiple policies to find
the best coverage for your home
text home to 33789 and talk with a
trusted insurance pro
about the right coverage for you text
the word home to 33789
let's go to rockville maryland where
amanda joins us amanda how can we help
hey uh thank you all so much for what
you guys do it's been a huge help to my
life and in so many ways and i'm really
grateful for it
i'm 33 years old i'm on baby step 2 with
about 63 000
in student loans left to go but my
question is actually a career question
um i'm at a point where i'm facing some
choices in my career that i haven't
really had to face yet
i'm really fortunate that i have a lot
of good options ahead of me
um the background is i'm a freelancer in
film and television
i recently came off of a long contract
with a great company whose culture i
love
i love my team there i have the
opportunity to go back to that company
but i would be going back to the exact
same role without much potential for
growth at this time or if ever
additionally i need some time off in
november for a commitment that i have
and the company more than likely cannot
allow me the time off
and then in the meantime i'm actually
being recruited by two of the largest
companies in the playing field
for a position that would be up the
ladder with more responsibility higher
salary
but as you know the interview process
takes some time
and my boss of the former company needs
a decision
from me by next week about my ability
to return so i just don't know how to
like approach
these really good opportunities that i
have ahead of me sure
so what would you do if neither one of
these were available to you
what would you do would you go get a day
job until you found the next
freelance or film opportunity i mean i'm
just curious because i think we have to
look at this
because there's two ways i think you
could go you could take this current job
knowing that you've got something else
going um i don't think there's anything
terribly ethically wrong there it's not
always the greatest you know
impression you leave when you sign up
with somebody and you leave two or three
months later
inside of that but there's nothing
terribly you know there's nothing
unethical about it but it's not your
first choice
uh so what would you do what would you
do to what could you do that's temporary
that would allow you to take care of
what you need to take care of because
you've got debt you're paying off so we
want to stay stable we want to we don't
want to interrupt income
so what could you do and play this thing
out because you got two companies that
are recruiting you there's a good
chance you might get an offer but we
don't know how long it's going to take
right exactly right now i'm with a
smaller company that i'm on a temporary
contract for
and that will last at least three more
weeks
but yeah there's still that question how
much time are you gonna take off in
november
um that would be about three weeks for
another commitment
okay and that's for another job
commitment that i have yeah so i think
this comes down to a math
answer what can i do to stay afloat
so that i can say no to this gig that
while it's safe
and now they're bringing you back doing
what you did before there's no ladder
and you've got these other two
opportunities that i'm guessing
correctly if i'm wrong if either one of
those companies
big boys call you and say we want you
based on what you're interviewing for
are you going to take it
yes absolutely yeah then i think you
have to hold out so if it's me
i'm staying afloat i'm treading water
and i'm probably not gonna say yes
to the previous gig because you're just
not gonna stay there
you're gonna stay there even if the big
boys don't come to you're not gonna stay
there for very long you're gonna be
looking correct
yeah exactly yeah so i'm i'm gonna be
patient and i'm gonna be persistent i'm
gonna tread water
financially i'm gonna do whatever it
takes but i am gonna say no that's what
i would do but i you know
look the reality is that's up to you
john you got anything to add to that
no i think you're right yeah i mean hey
don't overthink this yeah you've got to
take the shot
and this is a ladder you are in a race
right now with other people
i'd give everything you got throw
everything you got i mean fire
every connection bullet reference bullet
you've got in the industry
and let's try to land one of those big
boys because that's the ladder you want
to be on but i'm excited for you amanda
well yeah perfect amanda can i say this
too
you're being recruited by the big kids
right
yeah you're coming off a long-term
contract you're
the the market is telling you the world
is telling you you're really good at
this yeah
and sometimes when we get to
overthinking it we get those gaps in
space
you start doubting yourself never forget
to step back and detach for a minute and
realize i'm really good at this i'm
going to find good work
and now let's go play with the big kids
right say no to the good
amanda so you can say yes to the best
somebody said that i don't know who it
is hey man you should put that on a
jacket or something
i don't think of that i don't think
somebody else has got that one but it's
still good advice
from this day forward you're going to
give it to me i'm going to give it to
ken cole and i'm very excited about that
that's big time
all right back to the phones maria joins
us now in bakersfield
california maria how can we help you
hi uh thank you for taking my call ken
and dr john how are you guys
we are having a blast what's up good
good
i'm calling um moreso on the topic of
parenting so
um for dr john uh when
when i married my husband i got blessed
with three sons
and and uh my question today more so to
get to the point
is to ask how do i how do we help them
to so they get a lot of disappointments
at their mom's house and
okay we just lost her so i just lost you
we'll try to figure that out but you
know that is
uh we're trying to we got a little
technical jacket there she's working on
it
but this is interesting yeah yeah very
interesting because
what it what an interesting dynamic when
you've got step kids and you got two
environments
and very different environments at that
and the kids are having to toggle back
and forth
and what does that do to the kid if we
get her back oh there we go we got okay
we got about two and a half minutes
we'll see what we can do here
we may hold her over all right maria we
lost you there you were talking about
uh they have a negative environment or
negative experience when they go to moms
pick up right there right right right so
they're safety is not in harm or
anything but constantly when they come
back home
they they have uh constant
disappointment especially with
her boyfriend things like that so i just
want to make sure i want
to see what what are the best steps for
us to take
to to help them with that i don't
they're i just it's heartbreaking to see
them all the time coming home crying and
things like that so i i push their
fingers how
dr john says all the time and i just
want to know
what's the best thing to do first and
foremost
good for you like man i i've just
known and talked to so many step parents
over the years that want to make this
situation
all about them why don't my kid my step
kids don't like me or they won't respect
me
and here you are you flipped it around
yeah and you want to know how you can
best honor these three boys
who are caught in a in a nightmare
trying to decide which parent they're
gonna
they gotta they feel like the sense of
loyalty to both sets of parents and
they're toggling back and forth to this
environment and that environment
and it sounds like they've got a great
stable new stepmom
in you but they're also dealing with
their biological mom's boyfriends and
this and that's and
just becomes an absolute mess so good
for you for thinking of them first
that puts you way ahead of the game so
here's what i want to do
we're coming up here on a break and so
i'm going to hold you over the break
and then when we come back uh we can dig
into this a little bit more but before
we go
how old are these boys they are 11
9 and 7. 11 9 and 7. and how long have
you been
in their life five years five years
are you are you and their dad married or
do you live there
yeah and what are the custody
arrangements how long do they stay with
you
they they 49 51 they're they're here uh
most of the weekends and and
summer vacation and winter vacation
summer vacation and winter vacation very
cool so you get them a lot
so they're not huge fans of going to
mom's house huh
no not at all yeah okay sounds like
they're coming back
pretty wounded yeah pretty frustrated so
maria hang on
yeah we got a debt-free stream coming up
we got that free screen so hang on maria
then we're going to loop all the way
back
we're going to figure it out john is
john is taking over it will huddle
during the break but we're going to help
you out don't move and the rest of you
don't either this is the ramsay show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney we're taking your calls
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're talking money
we're talking your work we're talking
your relationships and right before our
last commercial break
maria joined us in bakersfield field
california
and uh she's a stepmom and got some
young
young men that she's now parenting and
there's some tension and stuff
uh in the other home the mom so
dr john take it away so maria
right when we left i want to talk to you
tell you about i was just so grateful
for your heart so i'm going to give you
a couple of things you can do here
um and it's not going to be a perfect
scenario okay it's going to be tough and
it's going to be challenging and this is
the road y'all are on
i think it's important to know y'all are
playing a long game here right you are
raising
three young men you are not trying to
make them happy every day and they're in
a tough situation
so the first thing you guys can do
always and i i trust that you'll do this
never ever ever talk bad about their mom
ever
ever ever okay if it's an abusive
situation then you're going to get the
authorities involved
if it is a situation where they just
don't like her it's uncomfortable etc
then you're gonna deal with them when
they're at your house the best you can
but you're never gonna talk bad about
mom
number two you're gonna make their home
safe
stable and consistent right
they trust you they're able to talk to
you they're your home is a place where
they go
right if they end up with abusive
boyfriends it's
unsafe they continue to come home and
they're crying that's where i want to
turn around and go back to
either the social worker that's worked
with with this divorce
or at some point you got to go back and
contact your divorce attorney and get
um potential new custody arrangements
because
even if they're physically safe if
they're coming home emotionally wrecked
then at some point they're
psychologically unsafe the trauma will
stay with them
for years and years and years then the
final thing for you
make sure you and your husband are
staying close together
don't take this stuff personally this
isn't an attack on you
this is somebody else dealing with her
challenges at her house
you all to make sure you're good so you
can support these
young boys heartbreaking situation y'all
do the best you can hanging on to them
and make sure they got a safe space to
come home to yeah maria you got this we
love your
heart heart we love your heart thanks
for trusting us and uh
best days are still ahead i promise
great stuff there
all right uh john i look out in the
lobby of ramsay solutions and on the
debt free stage
uh fantastic couple out there jay and
megan j
megan welcome hi hey guys how are you
how you doing over there i guess you're
here to do a debt free screen by the by
the look of the shirts
sir it says debt free on there even i
can figure that out
fun stuff all right where are you guys
from amarillo texas
oh wow that's a long way 806.
how much you pay off 163 000.
and how long about three and a half
years whoa wow
okay what kind of debt are we talking
about uh mostly
student loans consumer everything
everything cars credit cards cars okay
pretty normal
you're totally normal just regular old
west texans oh yeah
wow what was your range of income during
this time so we were at
um 120 uh to 180. oh
what do you guys have yeah uh so i'm a
finance and accounting controller for
trinity fellowship church
back home yeah and um i'm an audiologist
we we own a hearing healthcare practice
as well sure
yeah okay yeah that's really good so you
went from 120 to 180. yes sir
all right so what was the what what
happened there was it a promotion for
both of you
extra work what are we talking about
yeah just just over the time
um just between that uh three and a half
years that's exactly what it was just
promotions through
through work yeah okay so what happened
three years ago
that made you decide to go on this
journey
it's actually a little bit longer than
three years but he finally got on board
with me about three years ago
oh see this is why we saw the giggles i
love it did you see the nervous system
he looked directly at him yeah
he's a big dude he got nervous the look
was i'm going to tell the truth on in
front of
millions of people are you ready honey
and he was like i'm good and that's okay
yeah that is true you're a smart man by
the way thank you
thank you so okay so how long were you
trying to get him on board we know that
three years ago he finally submitted
yeah but how long were you trying to get
him on board it was probably a good two
years
which we don't recommend no no i was
doing the plan by myself
jay don't don't yeah what's the problem
i'm just looking at you and i'm totally
judging you a big truck or jeep big
tires
nope no no no i do have a truck but no
okay what was the hang-ups i was wrong i
was wrong what was the hang-ups
i don't know i i really don't i don't
know i mean
i just i i was like half dave i was like
dave ish
okay okay you know yeah um but you'll
mostly do it unless there's something
really cool that you want that day and
you'll just look at that so
i i like to golf yeah there we go okay
yeah all right that's enough of you yeah
you're a golfer yeah
yeah john looks down at his nose at
people like that because he's the real
life happy gilmore
you ought to see this guy golf he's
never seen anything like it golf trips
golf equipment
you know i got some buddies back home
okay we like our golf trips i get it
so what so okay so i'm gonna ask you
this jay so what happened three years
ago where you finally say i'm in babe
you know so for for me three years ago
it was in the process of when we were
buying our new house
and i get the the
final here's going to be your final
mortgage payment and i'm looking at it
thinking
you know this is doable but what's
unacceptable
is our car payment is almost if not more
than half of what that mortgage payment
was going to be and i'm like
that's insane like we can't do that like
with that car payment and this mortgage
payment we
we can't afford it yeah so yeah so
what'd you start doing
i mean so you've been on the plan megan
and finally
dalt over here decides to join in and
you guys get after it
what'd you do how intense was it the
very first thing we did was sell
the big brand new expedition
we got rid of it big beautiful
expedition so i guess that's that's more
to your
big g big tires okay we we had it turns
out you were right
so you sold the big fancy car we sold it
we got a hyundai sonata
and you know it's we're squished we're
still driving it we call it the sonata
cadillac
yes nobody's dead nobody's dead your
beautiful kids over here smiling
they're not you know zombies from no no
screens in the backseat
things like that that was the first
thing we did yeah immediately
immediately yeah like no questions asked
we we had to get rid of that thing
we were drowning in it so who are your
biggest cheerleaders
these guys right here yeah this is our
accountability group yeah
they are accountability partners right
here they did it with us
and so it was so much easier just to
when we're having a moment where we want
to take a vacation you know we've been
doing this for two and a half years we
deserve to take a trip
to text the rachel's and say we want to
go to mexico
no you're not yeah don't do that just
stick with it just
do it just just hang on yeah we're
almost there that'll work
we have a great church community as well
yeah all right so real quick
teach everybody listening that's have
haven't taken this journey maybe in the
middle of it they'll think they can
finish what's the key
oh man we say that there's three three
primary keys
the first one is get on the same plan
yeah like
you just have to be on the same percent
yup have to yeah second one is
accountability
find you somebody that's doing it with
you whether it's in a facebook group
somebody that's doing it in the church
with you yeah um yeah
we we did we um we're also coordinators
for
oh thank you very much yeah so so we've
we've led through
three or four classes yeah um it's hard
not to stay on the plan when you're
telling other people
you kind of got to walk the walk yes
yeah and then the third one for us i
think is when we finally sat down and
realized that god
actually has a plan laid out for
how he wants you to be a steward of his
money
so when we first started it was more
we're oh we got to do this because we
made really stupid decisions
and then when we figured out you know
god had a
it became less about discipline and more
about stewardship and that made it easy
it's amazing
all right so here's what we got to do
let's get the kiddos in while you bring
them in tell us who they are
okay we've got nolan nolan he's
and this is elliott she's six all right
is everybody ready to do the debt-free
screen you guys have practice and you're
ready to go right right
ready blow the roof off all right here
it is jay
and megan 163 000 paid off in three
years making 120 000 to 180
000 beautiful legacy beautiful family
let's hear
your debt free screen you guys ready
okay three countdown three
two one we're dead yeah
there it is yes
another family debt-free another legacy
another family tree
change really good stuff he is dr john
delaney i'm ken coleman
and this is the issue
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john delony and we're taking your
questions about life specifically your
money
your work and your relationships john
and i
specialize in those two areas i'm
helping people
find purpose and work but also get
the practical benefits of work the
paycheck a bigger one getting promoted
so that you can do that and move into
doing your dream job and then john of
course helping people with relationships
mental emotional health so we'll take
those questions along with of your
standard money questions
as well thrilled that you are joining us
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's go to chicago
illinois where christine joins us
christine how can we help
uh hi john hi ken how are you i'm a
little nervous right now
how are you doing you're doing great
yeah
what's up um i have an important
question to ask you in regards to
a job and career uh recently just
started a
newer job with a really good pay
i'm a health care provider working with
the under privilege and making a
difference in trying to help these
patients
awesome i'm just i'm just wondering at
this point
with everything that's going on and
trying to
mandate the vaccine for health care
providers
in a lot of places and now
knowing that the federal government has
implemented it
in the va system and it might eventually
trickle down to
private practices and administrations
and hospital administrations
how do you feel about compromising your
morals
for keeping a job so explain your
moral challenges with this even though
we don't know if you're going to
have this mandate come your way i do
like that you're walking through it but
let's walk it all the way out if they
say you've got to have it for employment
where do you feel like you are
sacrificing your morals
um my religious beliefs um
against the aborted fetal cells that are
being used
uh either in the process or
um in the actual vaccines
they have available yeah are you leaning
towards compromising
or are you leaning towards saying i
can't do this and i gotta walk
you were leaning one way or another when
you called which way are you leaning
leaning towards not compromising yeah
so you have to prioritize that and i'm
going to tell you something right now if
this is a if this is an integrity thing
or
a very deep religious held spiritual
conviction
i support that but you got to make plans
for it um
you know you you've got to know what you
can live with and what you cannot
and um you know i will tell you you need
to seek
a seek counsel i've talked to several
people in the last month
some on my show and i've got friends
calling me i've got a friend who called
me who's a state employee in another
state
and feels like it's coming down and
asked me the same question
and he has done some homework he went
and sought legal counsel
and i would seek legal counsel an
employment specialist
and i would get some counsel maybe two
or three different lawyers and talk to
about about the religious exemption i
will tell you
that uh it's going to be i think a grab
bag maybe 50 50 as to whether some
organizations will
say that's okay some i think will honor
the religious exemption i'm hearing of
that
and some will not and it's going to be a
time to choose unfortunately
that's where we stand but you know look
if you plan for this financially
and you've got a plan for if this
happens what would i do
meaning i'm going to walk i'm not going
to take it as long as you've got a plan
then i think you have to honor your
conviction there i'm not going to tell
you to go against your conviction
yeah what i would i would recommend two
things number one get some information
i've i've
uh when it comes to the vaccine i've
never heard of the particular challenges
you've mentioned
um i've tried to stay pretty close to
the science on it but i i i may be wrong
i've never heard that so i'd get i'd get
with some folks and
you're in the medical field so you can
get some good clarity on that the second
thing is
back out of this because this is a hot
hot hot moment
in history back out of this particular
issue
and ask yourself on any ethical issue
they ask you to start over billing
somebody they ask you to go ahead and
change this number on medicare they ask
you to
um fudge your mileage a little bit when
you're taking
taking these kids to their appointments
whatever the thing is
i always want you to double down on
doing the right ethical thing
for your heart for your family for your
conscience
and that goes back to what ken was
talking about on any particular issue
that's why that's why the emergency fund
is so important that's why having a
network is so important that's why
having friends in your life
emerge friends of your emergency fund
for life right that's why we do these
things so that when you're faced with
situations regardless of what they
happen to be
and you say i've got to walk out that
front door that you've got a
safety net you've got a cushion there
for you right yeah so
if you feel like this is coming down
what i don't want you to just
catastrophize it yeah i don't want you
to set yourself off into fight or flight
and start solving problems that aren't
there yet
and we can all do that we can ruminate
we can just sit there and
go down internet rabbit hole after
rabbit hole after rabbit hole and make
something
our bodies respond to an issue that
hasn't even happened yet
right and we can always get some more
information and some more information
but
um do start playing and if you have to
make a hard hard choices hard changes
um have that safety net there well
christine
the decision has already been made
you've already made the decision and i
respect that right
i respect men and women who will take a
stand on principle
and in this situation this is a
religious conviction
uh i will tell you to me it's about
freedom
and um you know you can do all the
research you want to and somebody can
i mean for every for every person that
says what you say that hey
i don't like the way the vaccine's been
developed and tested you'll have
somebody who goes
like john i haven't heard that so i
think he's right
you can go do your homework and make
sure that you're absolutely sure on that
conviction but
do not waver and you know people calling
and i appreciate the call
people saying hey should i do what i
think is right or should i do
what i think is expedient for me
professionally and folks
you know we live in america where we've
not had to make a lot of these choices
all the time
uh and and john's right it doesn't
always have to be a political vaccine
issue because this thing is big this has
become a political football
yeah pure and simple yeah um i don't
care what side you're on that's why i
like to get out of those and say what's
the
when you're faced with what you can't
get out of you you have to say in this
particular situation
she doesn't feel right about this for
the reasons that she
left out now you're right to say go do
your research and make sure that you're
right
because this is a monumental decision
right you don't want to make it right
right on
opinion or theory you got to know the
facts or the facts that didn't affect my
belief right however you're also right
this could be as simple as they're
asking you to fudge your expense reports
you know so that they can cook the books
that's equally wrong
and and i would say the same thing if
you feel wrong about that come up with a
plan that's right
you don't have to leave tomorrow that's
right but if you want to leave tomorrow
i'm fine with that too
but you've got to also have a a plan
conviction is important
but we also need to do it in a way
that's wise that's right
and i think that you address that we say
this a lot on the show
nobody makes good decisions when their
head's on fire right when they're
stressed and
um when you spend hours and hours and
hours
huddled around a water cooler or huddled
down internet rabbit holes
man it those are designed to set your
body on fire well i'm glad you said this
because i'm going to tell you something
right now and you may not agree and
that's fine yeah because you and i can
disagree agreeably we do it all the time
um
but i think you're right i i don't care
what
the biden white house is saying and i
don't care what your company is saying
on some level people have rights
and you can go seek legal counsel and do
your homework but whatever mandates are
coming or not coming right because we
don't know this is coming
we we're hearing all kinds of stuff of
course the reality is there will be
legal challenges to this stuff of course
there will be which means delays
right so to your point let's not all
freak out
and assume that we got to quit our jobs
because somebody's going to make it take
a vaccine that we don't want to take
yeah so
let's not jump to that conclusion
because i think it's that's not that
simple
i've worked for places where i have been
asked to
be in situations with i'm not
comfortable with the beauty was
i'd already thought through my my
ethical positions and so
when i came home and sat down with my
wife and said hey here's where we are
and here's what
it was this it wasn't a oh no what are
we going to do
those were difficult when i owed six
figures of student loans and we were
paycheck to paycheck to paycheck right i
put myself in a position where
holding my ethical standards was more
difficult yeah but we appreciate the
call christine
it's not easy stuff i love that you're
getting out in front of it don't make a
decision based on fear
make it based on facts hey i want to
thank our producer ben hill
our associate producer this hour laura
johnson back
in the booth i think my colleague dr
john deloney and you america
thank you for joining us this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
your money your work your relationships
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney
and we are here for you america it is a
free call to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five five two two
five let's go to phoenix arizona to
start this hour off thomas is there
thomas how can we help
hey ken john thank you for everything
you guys do i've got a quick question
today
um i am 24 years old me and my wife
and we're making about 140 000 combined
income
per year and um we've got
about a year or so now we're going to be
inheriting about
300 to 400 000 in single stocks from a
family
a friend of ours and i'm a huge number
this numbers guy and we're currently on
baby step two
um we've got a car that we're gonna have
paid off in a couple of months here
and we also have a home that
probably within six months after
inheriting this money we could
completely pay off i'm wondering should
i reinvest these single
single stocks into mutual funds and you
know kind of just work the baby steps
and pay off
our home in maybe you know five to six
years or should i
just cash out this money and pay off the
home
how much do you have left in baby step
two
um well baby step two is about probably
probably about fifty thousand dollars
that we're paying off in a couple months
here
okay and so then you're moving into baby
step three in just a couple of months
yeah uh-huh and uh how much you owe in
the home
uh the home we are going to be owing
probably about
at the time we received this inheritance
probably
um you know plus or minus you know 20
000 right around 400 000 bucks
okay so uh you're inheriting you think
between 350 and 400 we're not sure what
that number is it really depends on
timing yeah because it's all in single
stock
yeah well john you know this is one of
those deals where it's like okay
you know you're that stock coming to you
as an inheritance
i want you to sit down with one of our
smart investor pros i want you to start
with that like let's say i'm gonna go
okay
what's that going to look like uh the
tax implications i'm just not aware of
that if it's an inheritance of stock are
you aware of the single stock
so what i want you to do the best thing
to do is uh you you're following our
plan
i want you to get with a smartvestor pro
do you have a smart vista pro already
that you are
at least aware of i know you're not in
that step yet but are you aware of a
smart mr pro in your area
yeah and i actually am already with one
prior to
um prior to uh taking on this car debt
that we have we
we've got probably about thirty thousand
dollars in
retirement already and are on our own at
24 right
and um you know and i should have
practiced that inheritance that we're
receiving that's after tax
oh okay okay all right that solved my
thing okay so if it's me
i'm gonna pay off the house yeah i'm
going to fast forward
you know all the debt and now you're
rocking and rolling the next day
the only reason i wouldn't pay off that
house is if you're 24 you say
yeah 24. the only only way i would not
pay off the house is if y'all think
you're gonna move in the next
two or three years no yeah and i don't
think we will me and my wife we've been
we're it's our four year anniversary
coming up in a couple weeks we got
married young and we're we're here we're
for life for here
yeah pay it off the next day for the
next day because now you're already
there you're
i mean now you're the 15 is coming out
baby step four you're saving for the
kiddos and five
you this you're already through six and
it's all about seven
i'd pay it off instantly and then in
fifty
nine fifty let's let's let's give you
some more than that eighty years
somebody else all of your kids are
sitting down saying hey we all got four
hundred thousand dollars or four million
dollars
and how are we going to do this with our
houses right that now you're talking
legacy change
i love that congratulations thomas yeah
that was a small detail that we needed
that's good
if that's the money after tax absolutely
wipe it out
be done with it that's fantastic really
fantastic yeah
love that all right let's go to a social
media question here
chandler writes in on facebook how do i
keep from wanting to keep up with the
joneses when i see
everyone around me having nice things
i don't know what he's talking about
john i've never had that problem i don't
have no idea what he's talking about
so it can this is a good question for
you and me because we're both
strong-willed guys yeah
neither of us like being told what to do
but i am a sucker
for a filson ad i'm a sucker for a cool
car driver on the road and being like
i know i think i need to get that car
yeah or a rifle or a new
fishing rod man so i don't like being
told what to do i don't want people in
my head yep but they're in my head yeah
i i yeah i'm with you on the golf clubs
the classic cars
so i'll tell you how i have to do it
number one
it starts with intentionality in a
budget for me i have to know what i can
and can't do
number two i have i'm i'm hyper hyper
intentional we talk a lot about this on
my show i'm hyper intentional about a
gratitude journal
shifting my way of being towards
what can i consume to i'm so grateful
for what i
have and if that life presents itself or
ultimately if i save for a car for a
year
then i end up with a lot less car than i
was searching for because i'm i can get
by with
right so it's an orientation for how i
just
approach the world yeah i think that's
right i'd add two things for me
um because even in my gratitude
sometimes it's still that shiny thing
yeah and i start comparing myself yeah
and
i can get in that like hey how did he
get there
how does he have all this i mean i can
get there so what i have to do is i have
to focus on my priorities first
so what are my priorities what am i
putting my time and money into
because it's intentional you know we
live intentional so it's like well i'm
i'm sacrificing here i don't have that
but i have this or i'm working towards
this what are my priorities so i got to
bring it back to what am i focused on
what's my story what's my journey
stop looking at their story that's right
that's where you get all jacked up wait
a second he's got different priorities
or whatever
i'm making these decisions so i remind
myself number one of my priorities
and then i take a good glance at the
long term what's the vision
what vision am i trying to make come
true yeah with our life
because money's involved in that of
course stuff yeah stuff
is a part of all that and so if i can do
those two things
it does help me get back to that
ultimate place of gratitude
it it it's i have to shake myself no
it's maddening to me because
i you know me i'm a stats nerd
and i know that data says about
happiness and money yeah and i know that
happiness says about
how long it actually hangs on when you
buy the new car and how
much lower that happiness roi is when
you buy the second car
and i know how much i know what it says
that money doesn't
bring you this that other stuff doesn't
bring you
joy other stuff doesn't bring you past
basic needs doesn't bring you
sleep doesn't bring you a good marriage
but every person i know
wants to be the one like i'll try it out
right give me a couple million dollars
i'll see if i can figure that out right
and i have to constantly for me go back
to the data
and say i i keep believing this to be
true it is a myth it is not true
yeah this is what's real and this is
what's true right
it's good it's hard though it is hard
nobody's immune to this
hey and have a friend in your life
that'll say you're an idiot yeah stop
the stop
right you be grateful you pinhead you
know i
got some people like that a little
insult on that by the way is
that extra piece just perspective but
also an interesting told me she just
shakes her head
yeah just but that's kind of just being
a husband
i feel like i live in that perpetual
state of stacy shaking her head
believing laura johnson did it when i
used to work for her she just was always
like
ken and so you learned something hey
don't go anywhere more of your calls
more hope more breakthrough coming up
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by dr
john deloni we're taking your calls
about life now when john and i are
together we kind of have a fun combo of
course we can take your money questions
but i'm focused on helping you in your
work
working on purpose so that could be
figuring out what is that work that i
was born to do or
how do i get there i know what it is or
how do i get there or hey i know what it
is that i'm supposed to do
i know how to get there but fear
finances
failure family holding me back uh we can
talk about toxic stuff at work
that comes into jonathan we talk about
burnout what's going on there
uh relationships john talk about
relationship parenting marriage
and all this stuff of course uh is under
that
money umbrella we're talking about life
so we'd love to hear from you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
triple a eight two five five two two
five okay so
john i've got an article it's fresh
it's like those uh it's like the hot now
sign at krispy kreme
all right this is like this is hot wall
street journal so fresh and so clean
clean let's do it okay
um and here's the headline and and you
have an interesting perspective on this
yeah because of your higher ed
background yes so i'm really fascinated
okay
all right al lord here's the headline al
lord
profited when college tuition rose he is
paying
for it al lord is the former chief
executive student loan giant
sally may and he's got to complain about
higher
higher education this is where it gets
rich the irony is so deep right here you
might need a life jacket
exactly the price of college is too high
he says
paying for his grandchildren's education
in recent years he said
left him appalled at the tuition bills
that land on his desk
every semester this is a direct quote
boy
am i sure glad we saved for my grandkids
if the average income is forty thousand
or fifty thousand or sixty thousand
i just don't know how you do it for the
record al he's still out of touch
the median family income in the united
states right now is seventy eight
thousand five hundred dollars so just a
quick snapshot all right but that's the
medium but there's also a median
tons of outside that's right a lot of
people in that range he's talking about
yeah 40 000 or lower right
and he's going how do they afford it
well the news is al
they can't they don't but you set up a
system
where they feel like they might be able
to the irony john
uh so that goes on in this article where
he basically comes out and says
i knew what was going on um he was like
look
uh here's what happened i was a partner
in the government and uh congress gave
sally may an
unbelievable return they encouraged
banks to finance all these loans
and then it turned into this massive
massive company
where the stock holdings were worth 300
million
dollars uh and he says in this article
there's no question in my mind
i knew what was going on he knew that
they were making it
easier and easier and easier for people
to go into debt he's admitting this
um so there you go um when i read this i
was like
you have got to be kidding me coming out
saying yeah it's too much
yeah but they allowed it see because
higher ed's basically said all right
let's just keep jacking up tuition
because we're giving people vehicle to
do it and so i want to ask you this i've
been talking about this
malcolm gladwell's been big on this
issue you got harvard i think has a 40
billion
endowment columbia i think
top 10 endowments in the country their
staff
and even um some of their leading
educators
in administration have asked can we use
some of the endowment
to help pay for the graduate degrees and
they're not doing it i just want to know
what are your thoughts here how do we
not
feel like this is about big business and
not about education
yeah i've heard the phrase with some of
the schools um that they
are uh hedge funds with uh a student
component to them right
that they're just giant hedge fund
couple of companies haven't been inside
it's easy to think of an endowment as
just a giant savings account
much of endowment funds are in are tied
up in
a donor gives this much money and wants
it paid out to this
type of thing over there so it has
strings attached
tons of strings right so when i think of
an endowment i just think of a savings
account in my
and it's not how those always work now
you can get creative and find new ways
etc
i think at the end of the day you've got
a group of schools with massive
endowments
and thousands of schools that do not
have that and so to lump everybody in
that pilot
is tough so let's get away from the
endowment conversation let's just talk
about this has been a steady rise in
tuition it's just been going going going
going going and here's the guy that led
sally maine he's calling it's out of
control yeah it's too much
what what i mean
i was part of a think tank that we dug
into this thing the challenge here is
it's a strange strange universe um you
can actually create a
a college tuition model that has no no
loans
no uh no scholarships
that here's just what it cost to come
here and when people came back
it's the jcpenney model you know what
we're not doing any more sales we're not
we're just gonna it cost seven dollars
get a shirt come get a shirt and jc
penney
almost went away right people want this
idea that
i am gonna pay more but get a
scholarship and do with this and get it
it's just a game that's gone out of
control on everybody and
somebody outside that system is going to
come up and disrupt the whole thing
because it can't work
no and colleges i've known this
for years again i've sat with people the
clock tick have wept
they've like we know we've got to stop
doing this to kids and
they just can't seem to turn the nozzle
and um
unfortunately when you can't turn the
nozzles on your own house somebody will
come and do it for you
and you can talk to the blockbusters of
the world you i mean it happens yeah the
codex of the world
and there's a storm brewing it's coming
both ways it's been brewing and brewing
and brewing
it's hard not to think that higher ed
cares more about their fortunes than
your future that's what i say it's hard
man
and uh it's tough stuff so very
interesting stuff there it's uh
it i'll tell you this ramsay solutions
we're gonna get in this we're gonna be
disrupting this stuff i mean
because here's the deal people are gonna
get to the point where they're going
look i need to get qualified
and there's lots of ways to get
qualified well what you're starting to
see happen is
quiet proposals like the american
counseling association
quietly says why don't like why don't we
just
create our own program right um
when uh or and i just picked them out of
the year
when ge finally just says you know what
we're going to train you for 18 months
you can work for us
oh it's going to start happening it's
going to start chipping off so google's
already doing it so google announced a
major initiative last year okay where
they've got six month training programs
in several key areas yeah mostly
technology-based
but they're like it's like a hiring farm
system like the major lakes yeah and
they've got a farm
so can i ask you training as a citizen
so i'm a i'm a lifelong educator so my
bias is there
i always want our citizens to know about
history
and i saw that thing the other day that
this many middle schoolers and high
schoolers have no
concept of nazi german they don't know
what that story is right
that's tragic so you you've got history
you've got
basic science we've got folks like which
we talked about the code vaccine are
there
folks who we don't even have basic
science literacy across the board
so we can't even say is this is that
there's science there's
there's math there's just general
quote-unquote knowledge
my fear about having some of these
companies break off and say you know
what i'm gonna do an 18-month training
program come work for me
is you lose a collective knowledge on
the other side of it is
i we can't charge a hundred thousand
dollars for we can't it's impossible i
think you're making a good point how do
you find that balance well so
so because i'm pretty vocal on this
stuff yeah i've had some educators i've
had some educators come in and go what
is your why do you hate higher education
i go number one i don't yeah i respect
the liberal arts
but what i'm saying is is there's more
to the college experience
than just your liberal arts well yeah
and so you're going to have to get
trained you guys are going to have to
step your game up in training
people to be able to move into the
workforce and adapt to go worse
i love the focus on liberal arts and i
would say this that i'm i probably am
going to freak you out on this but i i'm
for a basic
level yeah um of history i think we need
to be teaching that better yeah
in the in the in the elementary middle
school and high school but once you get
to the college age
unless you want to go into history yeah
i could be like hey you know look we
we've got to make higher education about
preparing people for their future
so to me i go i love you know this i
love a custom
i love some customization meaning a kid
comes in and goes look
i want to go into this and we go hey we
think this would be good and i'm for
some core stuff at college
but i'm not as concerned about it i'm
more concerned about what you're talking
about
why is this true because of our current
education system
in k through 12. yeah i remember stuff
from history
from k through 12. i remember stuff
about science not a whole lot because i
don't like science
and but i'm not good at science and
that's what i teach and that's where i
think a lot
of the higher ed problems outside of the
pricing issue which is a whole other
thing
and you start rolling downhill and start
pulling that thread and then it comes
all the way back to
test space and kindergarten middle
splines we got a lot of you and i can
talk
so the bottom line is it's got to be
more more relevant
and it's got to be easier for people to
do all right i see some folks
oh in the lobby great crowd here don't
move for taking your calls
this is the ranch
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show on the
ramsey network joined by my colleague dr
john deloney he's the host of the dr
john delaney on the ramsey network
you're probably wondering how much time
did you guys spend on those names
was there a lot of creative people in
the room when we came up with those
dollars
yeah hours upon hours and that's what we
came up with i know uh what do you guys
think about the
uh ken coleman show yeah good we like
that okay let's go with that
so that's what we did that's what we did
same thing with you i wanted i had some
awesome rock band names that were to it
was going to be awesome
dude that's so great it didn't work all
right couple ways to engage triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you can also engage
with us on social media as well
uh john and i were talking during the
break and based on what he does on the
dr john
dr john deloney show easy you said huh
uh
focusing on relationships the mental and
emotional health
and then i'm helping people get out of
those dead end jobs
uh get out of some toxicity he and i
both deal with this so we were talking
during break so we're gonna throw this
out there
if you're in a situation right now
you're walking out the baby steps you're
gazelle intense
and you really need that job i mean it
it's the shovel
but you're in a really crappy let's just
call it toxic
nasty situation with either co-workers
or your leader or your leader
your leader is an impossible pinhead i
did an event with the entree leader the
other day
entre leadership that you know the group
here yeah about
leaders i want to hear about your bad
leadership it's the worst thing with
companies is the leaderships you're in a
horrible leadership situation you want
some advice from john and i
we love that i want to hear about your
boss so here's the deal we'll change
your name and your location
yes because we don't want you to get
fired we want you to leave and tell them
to stick it
right that's a great great song by
johnny paycheck
take this job and shove it yes uh play
it eight two five five two two five so
tell us about your ball
here i wanna do that but first look at
this we got another fantastic couple out
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage from
austin texas scott and holly welcome
thanks for having us yeah so you're here
to do a debt-free scream
very exciting okay tell us about how
much did you pay off
194 500 194
500 and how long two and a half years
what and we paid the first 140 000 off
in the first thirteen months oh
my goodness now does this include a
house
it does an audience what kind of debt
was it cars
cars wait a second am i guessing here
that you're a gear head
yes sir what kind of cars man
anything that has wheels no come on tell
me something there had to be a car or
two in there you're a little proud of
69 chevy nova i knew it i knew it
anything up to 2015 ford f250
how bad did it hurt horrible yeah
which one hurt the most
the ones that i did for this the whole
all right
all right okay okay and then the rest
was student loans student loans um
credit
cards wow okay what was your range of
income in this time
150 000 to 170 000. okay wow what do you
guys do
i'm a physical therapist okay oil and
gas industry
oil and gas now where's some overtime
here to get to that 20 000
bump or is it just gradual increases
promotions okay good quite a bit of
overtime
excellent you guys have a great salary
but i don't want that to overshadow you
all paid off
200 thousand dollars in in 28 29 months
that's a lot of money so you
you have a good salary but y'all were
major changes
was it a lot of you so uh tell us again
remind us how much you paid off in that
first 13 months you said
140 000. whoa talk to me about that
detail that for us
so we sold um everything i don't know if
you noticed our shirts and our friends
shirts but they say we sold everything
but the kids yeah
right before we literally did that we
unfortunately sold all his toys um a
razor
a boat and they were all paid off for
cash
so those were hard um and then his baby
we sold that we had a loan on it and
what's the baby again this truck oh
there
that was the day we sold it um i wiped
away the tears for that picture
did you really are you joking no i
thought you might be
oh bad wow so you sell all the cars
you're driving to corolla around austin
texas not near as cool as you used to be
it was a 20 year old vehicle yeah there
you go right
so that gets you going how how so
i mean it how quickly into all the
sell-off
do you guys go oh wow we are gonna do
this you really believed
yeah i think that was the hardest part
um
we were just talking about it before the
show was
him coming forward and saying okay i'll
sell my truck and
i kept pushing for that because it was a
big loan and
he turned around and said okay then
we're selling the boat and the razor and
they're both
and they're both cash and i was like no
no we don't owe anything on those
we don't want to get rid of that and he
said if we're selling we are selling and
we are getting rid of all of this debt
if we're going to do it we're going to
get it done
we're really big into going and doing
and traveling
and we were telling people no constantly
um
and the only thing we would do is home
vacations with these guys
our friends over here um people would
come visit us but we kept telling
everybody no
who had the first conversation with who
who sat down and said i'm scared
we owe a couple hundred thousand dollars
and i can't breathe
she's been talking to me about it for
quite a while yeah i just wouldn't ever
get on board with it
and what finally pushed you over the
edge you know it
it's one of those things like just being
up front and honest just really
tired of hearing about it and then you
listen to the dave ramsey show and you
hear the
about the people that have have done it
and how they're living life now
we're real big into trying to give to
our community and
and do work like that but um we really
didn't ever have the opportunity to
because we were living paycheck to
paycheck i mean we were doing good
but it was all going out just as fast as
coming in yeah
so two and a half years ago you finally
say i'm tired of her telling me we have
to do this
i'm going to start listening to the show
and then hearing the stories like you're
sharing
right now that was the moment for you
that led to it wow
and then when you said i'm all in it's
all right where you are you are
definitely all in all in or
go home or go go big or go home right
right yeah so we've heard a lot of this
but what is the mental or emotional key
or what's the discipline that you would
say to folks listening right now that
allowed you guys to walk this
you know first and foremost i mean you
got to be pretty strong with your
relationship you know
with your teammate with all your friends
that are going to do this with you
you know having that that physical you
know help
to go forward and just keep doing it
keep you on track
is the biggest thing that i would say is
go to everybody has to be all in
and you have to remember that there are
going to be fights you get you hear
we've heard these debt-free screams for
the last two and a half years
and people say it's hard but they don't
tell you
how hard it is and how stressful there's
times he didn't want to keep doing it
there were times i didn't want to keep
doing it
the first 13 months were easy because we
sold everything but after that it was
like
slow and plugging away and
we did things wrong and we'd get back on
track and
ride and then we'd fall off again and
get back on but we knew we wanted to do
it and we knew we were on the same page
on that part and that helped and then
having
good support system scott give me one
quick thing
to a husband who is sitting there and he
feels like his wife is just complaining
and nagging
and whining and what what would you tell
him
you're a texas male that sold his f250
it didn't get much more you know what i
mean
right and it's extended what do you tell
that guy man leave your ego at the door
man
that's right uh be all in you know be
supportive
and and ride it you know go with it so
great
how does it feel now
fantastic yeah it's it's very freeing
and it's something that
you don't you can't even explain the day
we paid off on
march 4th i was like we're done what do
we do now and then obviously we keep
going through the baby steps but that
moment
just knowing and our kids were like now
we can go do this
and we can give to this and we can
donate here and i love it those types of
things were just so
incredible it's just a friend what a
great legacy that the kids are talking
about in fact let's go ahead and bring
them up and introduce
the kiddos to everybody i'm sure they're
ready to do this screen they've
practiced
yes who do we have this is brecken um
he's ten
and taylee is eight brecken and taylee
did i get that right yes
okay brecken and taylor all right so if
they practice they really you guys are
ready
for i couldn't tell okay all right here
we go so in
the lobby ramsay solutions on the
debt-free stages scott and holly
brecken and how did i say it again
taylee
taylor got it yeah 194 500 and two and a
half years make it 150
000 to 170 000 let's hear your debt free
screening
all right count it down three two one
look at that another family
the kids get it so love it hey now we
can give what can we do with this money
that's the legacy of financial peace
don't move
this is the room to show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney thrilled to have you
with us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
is the number john and i mentioned this
earlier uh we're gonna have some fun
here we both of us were talking during
the breaks
and we we get a lot of calls about
people that are just dealing with mental
and emotional uh damage from work
john you know just difficult people and
a lot of times
it's an awful and i mean train wreck
awful human being
that's their leader and it causes
unknown
uh physical emotional mental challenges
and it ricochets through families it
ricochets through their
yeah and uh but yet you're going we'll
wait we we
we need the job i can i how can i change
jobs while i'm in the baby steps
or you can by the way i can help you of
course but it's also
this is the identity thing i hear a lot
ken but i'm uh
filling the blank yeah i'm an i.t guy
i'm a yeah i'm a roofer i'm a landscape
architect like
as in this is the only shop in town i'm
a that guy
so i'm stuck here yeah and it's like no
it's not true so we want to tackle that
holistically i want to hear about these
bosses
i want to hear about your radio your
leadership experiences so here's the
deal we're going to change your name and
your location
laura johnson is a is a pro i mean come
on
she's in the hall of fame it's the og
that's right so she'll change your name
location
and here's what we're gonna do john's
gonna tackle the emotional and the
mental stuff
and then i'm gonna come in and we're
gonna work on okay what's the path
out of there that's right because this
is a big problem yep oh so you got a
horrible boss
we want to hear the story oh what about
the jerk co-worker
that makes you want to throw your head
in an oven every day
are you looking at me ken no not at all
i'm just kidding no or if you
during cove and if you have been
promoted four times and now you got a
fancy title and they've given you
yes 11 new departments and no pay raise
yes because
are you not grateful right what do you
mean right oh here's one you're the
associate
associate to the assistant to the vice
president that's right here's one you
really like working from home
you didn't know it was your jam and now
you're being told you got to come back
in what do you do i need that income can
help we'll take it all on
and i tell you man y'all have been more
productive in the last six months
than i've ever seen yeah but everybody's
got to come back right yeah so yeah
let's bring it all in
there's a lot of stuff out there i want
to hear about these bosses
eight two five five two two five all
right let's all speak
of the situation sarah joins us in
lincoln nebraska sarah how can we help
i'm coming back to john how's it going
we're having a blast what's going on
with you
good um you said to call in about uh
some issues at work
hey we love it what is happening at your
workplace sarah
i'll try to boil it down um but
basically i
love my job and i love my boss but i
have a co-worker
who refuses to retire she's been there
for 33 years and i work in a police
department as a forensic scientist
so i have a lot of trauma
and mental issues already as it is with
just trying to deal with the work that
we deal with
but i think it'd be a lot easier to do
if i had uh basically co-workers that
did their job
and so i guess my issue is i have other
offers at other places but i'm not
willing to take
the decrease in pay which would be a
really big
decrease in pay um in order to combat
kind of
just a bad co-worker it's one of those
things like do i just suck it up and
and deal with it i've i've told my
bosses about it
and more or less they are aware that
i've tried to go to counseling to kind
of
get tools in my toolbox to figure out
how to handle that i've also
changed shifts so i avoid working with
her personally
but it's one of those things where i
think she's doing some unethical things
and when i bring that up i've been quite
all told like we don't agree with what
she's doing
but we're never going to fire her and
we know that personally no one gets
really along with her she kind of
bullies and intimidates a lot of people
and they're aware of that and they're
just like yeah we can't really change
her personality
so when she retires we'll just fix what
we know that she's
doing that we don't like that she's
doing okay so first of all sir
it's also a hierarchy yeah i'm first of
all
i i am so sorry
that you've taken this to your leaders
and they basically are saying we agree
we
agree we agree but we're not going to do
anything about it and i don't know if
they're scared of her
i could spend all my time on this but i
so that john and i can dive in a little
bit more
what what is happening with you changing
shifts
so you getting i know she's doing things
that are unethical but when you
change shifts where you're not directly
working with her does that make it
better
or uh is the fact that you know she's
doing unethical things just eating away
you like a cancer explain more
i think it's a lot easier for me i'm
flexible in my hours and that's easier
for me to just change this to avoid
that one-on-one my question is when you
avoid that which is great when you're
not a rounder
are you in a place now where you love
the job you said i love the job love my
boss so when you're doing that what's
your emotional state mental state about
her
when you're not on the same shift
it's great when i'm not on the same
shift unless i have to go to court and i
it's difficult to go to court and have
to
try to explain something that i know was
done
incorrectly on her end the attorney like
i've
confronted that too for cases and said
hey how do i handle this when i'm
testifying that something wasn't done
properly and
is that something i need to handle or so
hey listen at this point
at this point you've got to put in
writing a public protest
yeah i mean you've got to put in writing
to your bosses that there's
um unethical work being done that
there's mismanagement of cases
these things hey you've got an ethical
and moral responsibility to your local
community that's what you signed up when
you went to work at a police department
the second thing is is this type of
sloppy work or unethical work or have
you want to characterize it
is going to result in either bad guys
getting off or
good guys going to jail right and
that's notwithstanding just this person
is miserable to be around
yeah right and so at this point i think
the conversations
unfortunately you've heard me you may
have heard me say on my show not by your
hand but in your lap
an ethical issue fell in your lap as a
public official and you've got to put it
in writing and say
i'm going to go up the chain here unless
this is handled and remedied all right
so
sarah he's right about that but now we
got to start thinking about what's the
path out of here because if you do that
they're not willing to get rid of her
they may get rid of you right so you're
walking down a path where we've got to
have some options you said you had a
couple offers
are both of the offers a significant
financial step back or a slight one
no they're huge it'd be a huge downgrade
in in pay
okay so as well as it's a change in
hours and
they're not flexible all right so let me
ask a really naive question all right
are those the only opportunities that
could exist for you
to do the work that you lost no it's
just if i stay where i currently am it's
it's around family and stuff too so it
has other benefits as well
sure okay so what i'm saying is is where
else can you go and do similar work
just another organization another police
department is that possible
yes except with the payroll decrease
yes okay so what i'm hearing is no
you're telling me the only place to do
that forensic work
um that you want to do is where you are
currently so you're basically in a
you're kind of in a no-win situation we
hope that with what john's saying that
this puts the leadership in a position
where they do something about this but
if not
i mean when we talk about forensics and
the type of work there i got to tell you
one thing i'm going to challenge you on
and again i'm naive in the sense of
knowledge on your particular industry
but i know that the type of work you do
that there's
there are elements there are tasks there
are functions there are roles
where you can find similar work may not
be in law enforcement specifically
but you can find work like that do you
agree with me or disagree
yes i agree with that so you've got to
start looking yeah so we go
it's a function issue so for instance
john and i got out of what we were doing
we're communicators we're content we're
kind of teachers instructors
we're going okay where else can i do
that type of work and that's what you've
got to start to do
the investigative piece the analyzing
the solving
whatever you would say break that job
down uh very simply by making a one
sheet
what's the type of work that i do that i
love and let's start looking for
opportunities to do that what do it take
to get qualified how much will that cost
how long will it take to get me there
would a lot of thank you a client
when a teaching opportunity if there's a
million different look for that type of
stuff sarah you got to do it quickly and
then i agree with john you have a moral
responsibility to do something
sorry you're dealing with this hey more
of those kind of calls we'll help you
he's john delonia i'm ken coleman and
this is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcaster from the dollar
car rental studio this is
the ramsey show it's where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life
your money your work your relationships
and we've been talking about all kinds
of awful
awful work leadership issues that's
causing
people to feel burned out people to feel
stressed what should i do should i leave
it's a good paying job but it's
awful to go into dr john delony is
joining me i'm ken coleman
we are ramsay personalities and we host
our own shows
on the ramsey network and we're here for
you triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to atlanta
georgia where bobby joins us bobby how
can we help
hey how are y'all doing we are living
the dream what's up
um so i got a relationship question for
y'all i think that my dad
enables my older brother to his
financial detriment
and it's happened many times in the past
but specifically right now
my brother wants twenty thousand dollars
from him to
catch up on some past due child support
that he's getting in trouble for
and my dad usually bails him out but he
only has
he's 60. he only has about 150 000 in
retirement
with 600 000 in debt so he doesn't
really have the money
to keep bailing him out should i say
something to my dad and brother or
should i just let it go since i'm not
really involved
um i
that's an onion we just heard that's
exactly right man there's a lot
there what's you what is your dad
compensating for
uh my brother's mom wasn't involved in
this past
so is your dad feels guilty there you go
okay
yeah yeah so
there's two things at play here ken i'd
love to hear you hop in here too
at the end of the day this unfortunately
for you this is a conversation between
two grown men your dad
and your brother also you
um love these two men right these are
your families or blood
right and so i would say by proxy you
have the opportunity to have a
conversation
understanding that when you have this
conversation which i would if i was you
there's a there's a chance that you burn
this bridge between
both of them right and so what you've
got to do is put on your
responsibility hat and your what are you
trying to accomplish hat
are you trying to protect your dad from
your little brother because if so you're
gonna be going to a 60 year old man
who's trying to do well and say
um you know what you could be doing
better and no dad likes to hear that
from his son
right or are you trying to burn your
brother you sick of him
leeching off your old man so you're
gonna try to go through your old man to
get to your brother
again you said i'm succeed i'm getting
that so right i want you to be really
clear
about what you're heading into i can see
a really remarkable father-son
conversation where you sit down with him
and say
i want you to have permission from your
other son
to stop this your dad you did your best
we love you of course there's crazy
stuff in the past you don't owe us
you don't have to play ketchup by by
making yourself unstable in the future
because let's be honest based on this
trajectory bobby i mean uh david
you're you're the one that's gonna be
taking care of him he didn't have any
retirement right
correct yeah you're gonna be one having
to clean this mess up and i think
a honest conversation about hey i want
you to have permission to not have to
click
to to try to fix anything from the past
dad
is is warranted it's great i would have
that conversation
but you have to be prepared for what's
on the back end right for him to say hey
forget you
um for your brother to find out and say
who heard you went to dead
like all that kind of nonsense you've
probably been dealing with that your
whole life is that fair
yes true yeah um is your dad gonna be
receptive to that conversation
i think he will be yeah yeah he's
usually pretty receptive i think it's
more
gonna be an issue with my older brother
i wouldn't talk to the older brother
just just my opinion um if it's me
that i don't know what the benefit of
that is i and maybe i'm cynical i don't
know john yeah do you all talk to each
other it depends on the state of your
relationship i think
no we do not okay oh yeah it's a waste
of time so i'm talking to dad
and john told you how to do that i don't
you know look if it's me talking to my
dad i'm going dead look
look you're such a good dude your heart
is amazing and
and but i'm just sitting here looking at
your retirement and i'm looking at you
i'm looking at your situation not my
brother's i'm not here to talk about him
i'm not here to talk about what you've
done for him i'm only approaching you on
this
as your son who's worried about your
financial situation because i'm going to
take care of you
but dad i think you've done enough and
i'm not telling you what to do
i'm not asking you to do anything but
i'm asking you
i mean well i guess i i'm asking you to
go is this really going to help the
situation right
and how much is this going to hurt you
if you try to help
i think i'm couching it with that
posture but i'm not talking to the
brother because
i think uh i'm hoping that it's a
confidential conversation between you
and your dad and that your dad doesn't
even bring it up
because the brother situation is already
not healthy there's not much of a
relationship there and i think that that
makes it more
of an issue and hopefully your dad goes
you know what
bobby's right and this isn't probably
this isn't a
hey man older brother got laid off again
he's working hard and he's trying to
make rent
this is 20 grand of he's a deadbeat dad
yeah let's just call it what it is
child support right yeah and this is the
third time yeah he's a bum dude
so this is a pattern yeah so he needs to
hit rock bottom and
and and let me tell you something this
is hard all right i hate seeing my kids
learn painful lessons i got three teens
unfortunately we haven't seen a whole
lot of pain but even the minorities i'm
like oh
yeah but you know what it's time for
your brother to feel the sting
but there is a sense of dad thinking i
played some role in this
and i will keep i'll go to the ends of
the earth and i get that sentiment
yeah it's that moment when you cross
over and you're enabling it right
yeah there's been no reason for your
brother to get a job and step up and do
what he's supposed to do
and pay child support for god's sake if
you won't stay
if you won't be a dad at least you can
pay for the kids food and diapers for
crying out loud
right but he's not and now we're to the
enabling part so
it might be good for dad to get in his
face if dad's got it in he might be good
but you know that's just me
that's where i'd be um i i would just be
in his face saying it's time for you to
put on your big boy pants
but i don't know if that's going to work
it's not it won't but yeah bobby thanks
for your heart man
have a great conversation but have it
gently and uh with an open hand there
all right uh we've been we've been
asking for some calls we got him coming
in hey uh i'm i'm in an awful work
situation i got a horrible leader
uh it's not leadership it's leader i
want to hear you know what i'm saying
and you got that problem i want to hear
about the bosses all right here's some
fun stuff how about a couple of funny
work fails jeff
okay we've all we've all blown it at
work embarrassment or whatever
how about a little humor here uh these
are from the internet i once called in
sick
in order to go to another job interview
only to find that my boss had done
exactly the same thing it was sitting in
the same waiting area
who got the job neither one of them by
the way oh how about that it's an
awesome one you think you're playing
hooky and
applying for a new job and you walk in
and your boss is there
this is a sign that you're not in a
really great company
wow here's a fun one on my first day of
work
big pressure day i accidentally called
my boss
daddy whoa
oh man can you imagine looking over at
dave and be like
hey daddy can i no i would resign
immediately and clean my desk
that's exactly hey the other day i still
check i don't even want that
meeting and i stood up and said hey guys
i'll be right back i gotta run go tt
oh you have a you have a toddler dog
daughter but the room got quiet and i
just said i'm i'm sorry
yeah i'm going to the bathroom well john
we've got some good news we're going to
take a short break so you can go tea tea
i will go tt
for the rest of you hang on we're coming
right back with your calls this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why
they offer benefits like tuition
assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
john deloney and we're thrilled to have
you with us triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five imagine
what your income could do for you if it
wasn't tied up every month a credit card
bill student loans or car payments
how much different would your life look
than it does today
that life is possible and it doesn't
have to take as long as you think it
starts with financial peace university
the class that's helped
nearly six million people learn the
proven plan to get out of debt and build
wealth
but it's more it's not enough just to
learn that plan you got to put it into
action every day and you do that
by budgeting with every dollar and you
can
get both of those only at one place
ramsay plus
is the place you can create a life where
money works for you not against you it's
time to ditch the debt
for good start your free trial of ramsey
plus
by texting trial text the word trial to
three three seven eight nine that's
trial two three three seven
eight nine blinds.coms 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsay to get the best
deal today's question comes from laura
here in tennessee we relocated last year
due to my husband's job
and i took the first job that was
offered to help our family financially
covet happened and then the ceo laid off
several employees and now
i'm working 12 to 14 hours per day
and weekends i'm burned out and it's
affecting my health
but the problem is in our small town the
average salary is forty thousand dollars
a year
and i'm currently making seventy
thousand dollars am i stupid
to leave my job in this security we have
saved up thirty thousand in case i quit
but i'm not sure what i would do next
well john uh these questions are tough
when you get something like this it's
got a lot of layers
and we can't go back and forth and ask
them questions but based on what i'm
seeing
number one you're not stupid to take
care of your health
and you're going to be forced to stop
this
your body will stop that's right and uh
so the fact that you saved up 30
000 um in this case i'm okay
again we don't know their debt situation
we don't know much here but if we can
plan financially
by either cutting costs tightening the
budget saving some extra money
to get her out of this situation and
find something else and we adjust our
lifestyle
if that's what needs to happen then do
it but the first thing i'd love for you
to do is go to your ceo and go hey
thanks for keeping me number one
number two you know that i'm stepping up
i'm working 12 to 14 hour days seven
days a week
i think you understand i want to be here
but i can't keep this schedule up
can you help me help you because i want
to keep stepping up i want the job
but can we sit down and talk to a
situation there's there's a posture of
humility and hunger and
gratitude but i'd start there it's worth
at least raise your hand going
how much longer are you asking me to do
this yeah so i've been a part of several
organizations that had
significant human reductions right yeah
i had to let people go
and one of the things that when you're
on the side of the ledger that gets to
stay
is right we've talked about this before
but you go to fight or flight yep
your brain goes into panic mode and
nobody ever stops and has that question
i'm 14 hours in seven days a week and
sometimes
a simple conversation with your ceo they
say oh gosh take care of yourself you're
one of the last ones we've got sometimes
they're not aware
they're not aware because they're also
burning their life is on fire right
that's right and so letting somebody
know hey i need to
start taking care of my weekends i need
to start protecting my family i haven't
seen my husband in a year
i haven't seen my wife in two years um
what does this look like and again i
love that humbly
not not accusation not all fired up
youth baby
hey look so now we're settling into a
rhythm here and this rhythm is
unsustainable yeah
and if they fire you for that
conversation you were going to fall off
anyway yeah
it's just a don't forget to assume that
they won't work with you don't walk away
from 70. that's right let's just see if
we can figure it out
and uh those come from ken why you you
talk to us all the time
why are why do people avoid that
conversation okay i'm gonna tell you
what i believe to be the wife okay
listen in thousands of people
yeah yeah but well but you've got the
psychology training so this is fun okay
the why on the surfaces
they don't want to deal with the
confrontation okay even though
it doesn't have to be confrontational it
feels like confrontation yeah so that's
my way of saying it it's kind of yucky
yeah they're like the idea of sitting
with my boss and going
um hey i i don't think i can keep doing
it this way it's physically bothering me
we're worried they're going to
immediately fire us you're done so we'd
rather leave on our own
with an unknown than deal with somebody
looking at us going what's wrong with
you i'm going to fire you
are you a loser are you uh yeah and so
that's what i mean by confrontation part
of it is the fear of being fired yeah
but you'll suffer instead of going for
that unknown will you help
yeah i want to be here yep tell me
what's the real layer there i think it's
the
our bodies solve for equilibrium we get
addicted to stress chemicals
right you can get addicted to
the chaos and the drama and you can get
addicted to
literally everything's on fire and we
don't have a picture in our head of what
a good hard-working busting it all day
but then being able to go home and be
with your family we don't have a picture
what that even looks like sometimes
so we don't know what we're trying to
solve for and so we end up waiting until
there's a crisis
and then we just run around and we play
avoidance right so
you gotta lean in like you said what do
you what are you aiming for
and it always starts with the humility
conversation and i'll say one other
thing too that also it's not just
confrontation it's the what
what's going to be on the other end of
it the unknown so what we do is to your
point
i've never heard that before we're
addicted to those chemicals we go
i'm pretty much physically and
emotionally miserable i'm out
but well but we'll hang on really too
long and we'll go but at least i know
what that's about
that's exactly right it's terrified to
walk to the boss's office and go hey
i'm afraid yeah yeah it's when when
you've been overweight 40 pounds and you
go lose it
your body solves for that back yeah
right it will gain that weight back
because that's where it they know
even though it kills you even though
it's it's what you know that's why you
can get out of a toxic relationship
and you find yourself right back in
another one because that your body will
solve for that equilibrium so you got to
change the equilibrium and you can only
change that with
peace right with a destination of where
you're going so
i love that idea of having that
conversation hey let's go to a youtube
question how about that
we love well shout out to the youtubers
a little shout out to the youtubers out
there
uh sydney writes it a very interesting
question john
do you have any advice for choosing a
therapist when you're starting
a mental health journey this is fabulous
question yeah i love this question
so number one some some places
wherever you can get in right start
there um i've got a
guy do you mean because it's it's an
emergency go to get to the er
is that what you mean no it's it's it is
the demand on mental health care in the
country is so
overwhelmed that you call a therapist
nowadays
and it may be a six month wait oh four
months wait so you go wherever you can
right
i got a partnership with betterhelp.com
you can go betterhelp.com they'll give
you it's it's
online therapy right you can do it
through your tv in your living room
that's if you
have a safe place there but um sometimes
it's getting in
the most important thing is lining up
with somebody that you feel comfortable
with and what comfort means is
you will tell the truth and nothing but
the truth so help you god
and that they are able to listen they
create an atmosphere we feel comfortable
and here's where that's kind of
challenging
is can you and i go to the same
therapist i might walk in
and be like this guy's this guy's a
scammer i'm out of here and you may walk
in and your shoulders drop and you say
that's for me
yeah so i always encourage people to
find somebody
um that is in your local community that
has a good reputation that your friends
or someone you know or your colleagues
refer you to
you go sit in there and after two three
four sessions if you think i'm
i'm shielding myself i'm not being
honest here then walk away see that's
good to hear because i was you know i
was gonna ask there's no damage done
by going two or three sessions with one
person not feeling it and going to
somebody else it's not like
it's not like you're starting a new
regimen as far as medicine you're
talking to somebody that's right and
um you don't owe them anything they're
grown-ups
right they're big boys girls agree with
that they'll be fine
it's the same as when you go to to talk
to an advisor about your finances and
you kind of feel uncomfortable and they
start kind of selling you
and you just don't want to leave get up
and walk out yeah walk out right
this is your mental health but
ultimately the person the
the research tells us the most important
thing with a mental health practitioner
is the relationship and so you got to
feel safe you got to be able to tell the
truth
you got to not lie and you got to go
and go and keep going go it's good stuff
and can i just tell you i mean john's
john's professionally trained
i've done it can we just get over the
stigma of what
somebody thinks when you walk in the
lobby they're just as messed up and just
as broken as you are
just go tear the band-aid off and just
speak to somebody who's a professional
who knows how to see you
it's so important incredible man it's
incredible yeah nothing to be scared of
uh i'll tell you what you don't need to
be scared of it's more of the ramsay
show
it's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague
dr john deloney we're ramsey
personalities and we are here for you
taking your calls about life money your
work your relationships
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right let's go to jared who joins us in
st
cloud minnesota jared you
are on the ramsay show how can we help
hello hey jared how can we help
good um say i've got a big relationship
issue i'm hoping you guys can help me
out with
bring it on what's up so me and my
fiance
we've been together roughly four years
engaged coming up on a year
and i've gone to her with the total
money makeover as well as the five
languages of love and
several other like let's get a good
foundation before we get married
and i sit down explain to her this is
extremely important to me
i've read the books front to back listen
to the audio tapes
and i cannot get her on board with
anything and i
really don't know what to do why won't
she get on board if you had to if
for you to diagnose it why won't she get
on board
or let me ask it more directly why does
she value what you want in this
relationship
so little that she blows off your heart
your passion your your um contribution
to this relationship
why does she devalue you so much
i i think a lot of it comes from both
the relationships that we have
you know my parents and her parents to
look at nope
nope nope nope nope what is it about you
wow that's depressing john
um i guess i'm one of these people
that before i even go to
her with like the the total money
makeover
like i read the book front to back i
knew everything
here's the budget the x amount of
dollars in out
in between and then i it cures
everything and i lay it all out in front
of her
what else do you do that with
i any little hobby
okay let's go on vacation
we're going point a to point b fourteen
thousand dollars
i mean i know every in and out before i
even bring anything to her
so is there a possibility that this
woman you love
feels that she is a data point in your
spreadsheet
or that she is a cog in the machine that
you are building
for your life and that
total money makeover love languages is
just another scheme
is just another something or other that
you have prescribed for her
life to come
i can see it that way yeah my guess is
she can too
and so at some level here
she loves you she wouldn't have been
with you for four years do you think she
loves you
yeah she does and she's also developed
an alt
universe where she does whatever she
wants to
she lets you do your little thing and
you're probably on to the next thing in
the next few months right
and she has now learned to love you and
just let you be
my wife has done the same thing with and
i'm speaking with authority here because
this sounds like my house
um i come home and say guess what honey
we're all gonna learn how to play guitar
we have a family band
and when we first got married she would
say that sounds ridiculous and stupid
and you have grad school and this and
this and this
now she goes cool john that's going to
be fun
because she knows in about three weeks
i'm going to be on to the next thing
right
all right so i have a question i'm
listening to this how much of this
is she doesn't like this idea regardless
of all this i i don't think the ideas
even matter at this point
oh so what does he do i think he sits
down and has that conversation do you
think
have i turned you into a project honey
we're about to get married we're about
to spend our life together and i feel
like i've come at you with hobbies and
vacations and stuff
is there a possibility that over the
last three or four years
i've turned you into something a problem
to solve
i've turned turned you into a widget in
the life i'm trying to build for us
and i've stopped listening to you what
do you want this thing to look like
and what i want you to do man is i want
you to bring her
into the the picture painting process
that you all are doing together
okay i think that the total money
makeover will become a part of your life
just because it makes sense it's foolish
to not do it
but right now it's just another scheme
in a long line of schemes
and you're painting a picture for your
relationship that she's not even allowed
to pick up a brush
gotcha yeah that makes is that fair a
lot of
yeah very fair and here's here's the
danger there
she's gonna paint a picture for her life
she'll just do it without you
and i remember distinctly about a decade
ago and then it happened again
three or four years ago where i realized
i had put my wife in a position where
she had to paint a picture because i had
excluded her from the one i was painting
and i gotta keep going back and i gotta
keep going back and now i've developed a
rhythm where this is just a part of our
life where i keep coming back to the
table and making sure
we're both working on the same canvas
yep
but i but you but doing all that john
he's still got to make it clear this is
important to me that if we're going to
get married right
this is how i believe we should handle
money what questions do you have
still take it back to her right so the
question becomes less
i want to do this thing for our family
and more i am
terrified i can't breathe with all this
debt yes and give her some why and not
how
that's he's just overwhelming her with
another plan another plan hey let's go
on a vacation
not for us to to spend time together not
for us to deepen our relationship not
for us to get some rnr
but so we can do this track that i i
found and i got us a plan and a plan and
a plan to plan
that's different right so i want you to
sit down with her and say the debt in
our relationship
makes it to where i can't sleep and i
can't breathe and i can't fathom
bringing kids into this relationship
i can't fathom 20 years down the road
when we still owe this money
will you be a part of painting that and
that's a different conversation then
honey i got another plan for us right
yeah that's right
that's absolutely right and then she's a
part of painting that picture yeah thank
you for the call jared it's an awesome
thing
hey you're a good man jared i'm glad
that you called and said hey how can we
how can i turn this thing around
um i want you to go to her and ask for
her input for the first time yeah
yeah good stuff triple eight eight two
five five two two five
uh let's go back to we're getting some
fun questions from youtube we're
kind of going hey fire those away in the
chat room so we only got a couple
minutes we'll do this one okay
all right because this is a fun one yeah
all right what's that fun was a sad one
but it's well
it's different it's unique right i
haven't heard this one yeah so jack
wrote in i keep hearing the phrase
toxic positivity what is it i have the
same question i think i know
but take that one on so it's the other
side of the bell curve we all know
eeyore oh we all know oh he can't find
his tail he's depressed my husband never
never picks up the shoes my wife always
wants to watch her show
is she a great wife yeah she a good mom
yeah
does she love you yeah it right and
she's like what are you doing
this is the opposite of that hey you're
uh
your husband's cheating on you hun yeah
but he provides food
and uh he is always right toxic
delusional optimism that's right
okay and it's not i'm an optimist by
nature no i said delusional
word there there's a wow um well he left
me so um it's probably for the best
so i'm just gonna find the happy here
and your house is on fire well the
furnace needed to be replaced
we had you know what um that we probably
needed some more carbon in the
atmosphere that's probably a character
on saturday night live
it's something it is right but it's a
it's a coping strategy it's an inability
to say
i am in a mess this is hard right now
and i need to grieve this my heart's
broken
and that man sometimes people i've heard
this phrase several times especially
people who work in trauma
they say if i start crying i'll never be
able to stop
and one way to combat that unhealthy
it's pathological but an unhealthy way
to combat that is just toxic positivity
i'm just gonna ignore anything negative
and we'll just continue to
we'll repeat those phrases that we see
on bathroom walls and on pillows
right that are crocheted on those little
signs and bathroom walls not on the
seat on the bathroom walls but we don't
have time for this but uh next time
we're together on the ramsay show i
think we might
break down toxic how do we know if it's
toxic or something else because
i'm afraid this word is worn out out of
control so what's the difference between
that's not great versus toxic because i
hear toxic i go i don't want to touch
that
i think in batman like a batman movie
where you fell in the toxic slime and
you die you melt you melt versus
not so great yeah the people it's kind
of crappy i'm uncomfortable yeah yeah
this is nothing
i don't know you got to be careful with
that word i'm with you pause the next
time you want to say toxic pause and go
am i going to melt and die maybe we
could start there
this is what you come to the ramsay show
for right there that kind of depth don't
move we're coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague dr john delony
thrilled that you are with us triple
eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
today's scripture
comes from micah 6 verse 8 he has shown
you o mortal what is good
and what does the lord require of you to
act justly
and to love mercy and to walk humbly
with your god our quote from helen
keller
character cannot be developed in ease
and quiet only through
experience of trial and suffering can
the soul be strengthened
ambition inspired and success achieved
you know john you and i were talking
earlier that
it's sad how little history we americans
know
i think if there was one woman that
everybody ought to know
every time they hear the name and
everything about her is helen keller
unbelievable strength she pulls a lot of
excuses off the table for me
anytime i think you know this is too
hard no
it's not you know what i mean what an
unbelievable story i think we gloss over
the quote like that when you think about
the woman
and what she went through yeah
i i would listen if you're a parent i
would teach your kids about helen keller
and if you're a parent i would teach
your kids and yourself around the
community that rallied around her
yes oh no question she had a lot of
people in her corner too yeah and we
tell that whole story but our community
just supports each other it's awesome
that's great
all right let's go to kalamazoo michigan
and chris is on the line there chris how
can we help
um well i'm disabled facing divorce
um and trying to find the correction
oh man i hate that for you chris what
happened man
uh what do you mean by what happened
what was what the situation
yeah well let's go i'll tell you what
let's go with the disability first what
are you facing
um my broken leg for the last 17 years
will it not heal no small
revision surgeries what not it hurts the
sand
so are you primarily wheelchair or
something no
i no i i limp okay okay gotcha all right
and talk about the divorce what's going
on there um
two and a half decade marriage and she
decided to hook up with somebody that
she knew from high school
um i'm sorry dude when did this happen
no it's been going on the last year okay
when is the divorce
i'm hoping the date will be soon yeah
and so you called us and asked what's
next i'll ask you what's next
um i would like to find some purpose for
my life something
maybe help others with you know my life
challenges that i've been through maybe
to help others but
just don't know how to go about it okay
oh now i love this
so chris uh i'm gonna let's start with a
big fun question and i want you to if
you can disconnect your brain for a
second answer with your heart
okay i want you just just let your heart
answer this question
what would you try tomorrow if you knew
you could not fail
you knew that you could not fail and
that you would really enjoy it but you
didn't also have to commit to it for the
rest of your life
what would you do chris wow that's a
pretty tough one there i
really i know but here's what i know
chris i've asked that question
thousands of times and i know that when
i asked it
there were ideas that were popping in
your head i know this to be true
but it's hard to kind of fire something
off but we're not holding you to it
chris
and there's nothing to be ashamed of so
i'm gonna ask it again what would you do
chris what would you try
even an area who would you help how
would you help them
and you could get paid for it what would
you try chris
i'd probably help people dealing with
pain
yeah yeah there's a whole lot of purpose
there
what's it been like for you to deal with
17
years of a debilitating pain that
affects your ability to just
function normally and walk that's what
it does it messes up your whole ability
to function
yeah yeah what kind of work do you do
now
as i said i'm on disability okay you are
on full
disability yeah okay let me ask you this
how
how limited financially i'm trash i get
you i get you we're going to help you
with that by the way
so what could you do is it something
that you can
sit at a desk uh sit and talk on the
phone
over video i mean what tell me what the
physical limitations are beyond pain
well that's i think that's the biggest
problem is the pain just debilitates you
to the point where you just don't want
to do nothing
you know when it hurts to stand up it
sort of sucks
but if you were helping somebody yeah it
would probably
probably outlook to be able to help
somebody else deal with it
sure it would distract you yeah
well that it gives you that purpose
you're talking about it
gives you yeah contribution that's it
and that's and that's that's what i talk
about every day and i think there's
something there
and i think you've got to get to a point
where you okay i still have some talent
so the fact that your leg uh is causing
all this
physical and mental pain does it take
away from the fact that you still have
talent
if i interviewed everybody that knows
you chris i went around kalamazoo and
wherever else they live and i said tell
me what chris does best what would they
tell me
i don't know try and help others yes
come on there's something else there
talk to me about a technical skill or a
hard skill that you're just good at
doing
talk to me chris tell us yeah i got a
history of
good mechanical ability but it sort of
gets taken away in here
i get that i don't have a physical
ability i get that let me push back
chris
but a mechanic is not just good with his
hands or her hands
the mechanic's good with their brain
they can see things that i can't see
they can analyze and then they fix the
problem don't you still have that
mechanical brain chris
well yeah i i went back to school and
tried to do something in the medical
field but it was just a little
physically demanding there you go all
right now john and i can't solve the
physical part
and john i want you to come in and let's
talk about some of the emotional stuff
but i want to
get to the financial chris here's what
we're going to do for you
chris in just a moment we'll put you on
hold and laura's going to get you in
ramsey plus
it's going to get you financial peace
university we'll get you a copy of
dave's book
that's helped millions of people total
money makeover i want you to read it i
want you to do it because i'm telling
you brother you can do it we've got a
plan for you to get your financial house
in order okay
and i know it's tough because you're on
disability um
uh john i'm gonna turn it over to you
because you know this guy's been through
this the medical stuff the mental stuff
but
but chris here let me tell you something
you have got to find a way to use that
mechanical brain
because that brain still can add
tremendous value in so many places in
this world because
really you're that mathematician you're
that problem
solver and there is value there are
things you can do
but i would also want you to look into a
little bit more
uh on the helping people side of things
and how we could get you qualified
so um i'm going to turn you over to john
because i want john to encourage your
heart because that's a big part of this
but we're going to get you in ramsey
plus where you get all that plus every
dollar we're gonna get you and laura
let's also get him a counseling session
where we can get you with one of our
coaches uh that's our gift to you
and get you a starting point and get you
off into this and i also want you to
consider calling my show
uh in the next couple weeks and let's do
a deep dive on some possibilities john
chris are you heartbroken that your wife
did this to you
yeah i actually believed in my vows she
did there you go hey
get your heart broken are you
heartbroken that you're stupid i'll heal
yeah yeah sucks it happens it does hey
hold on it happens and yeah
and right now you've been dealt a couple
of hard hard hands
and it's heavy and i want you to find
somebody you can grieve with
whether it's a professional whether it's
a buddy there in town
i want you to sit down and take
ownership of this this
sucks it hurts and it's hard
hey i'm alive i'm blessed really yeah
don't blow it off
we just talked about toxic positivity
you got to sit for a second this hurts
okay it hurts it shouldn't have happened
and it did
right and then and then
you still have value to add to this
world to your
neighborhood to your family to your
friends
and you know this your brain does what
you tell it to
and so you're going to have a period of
grieving that you deserve
and then you're going to work real hard
on turning the
turning the reflection in the mirror
into somebody that you don't like into
somebody that has value
and that somebody's going to go make a
difference in your community and you're
going to go out there and you're going
to get them
okay we've given you some tools and
resources you're going to use them now
brother
you're going to use them because you
have value and you're worth it
chris you're in the storm but the sun is
coming get somebody
with it in the storm we got some help
coming your way hey i want to thank
our producer today ben hill our
associate producer laura johnson i want
to thank my colleague dr
john delaney and we want to thank you
america this is your show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you